[Music]
let me blow it you've got in sixteen I
think it might be good to have a doctor
look at you sometime might be good to
have doctor with you sometime ain't got
no bullet in me cuz I was covered you
may have heard there was prison break
it was Bonnie and Clyde governor this
has to end they committed dozens of
armed robberies in several cold-blooded
murders what do you plan to do about
Bonnie and Clyde we will capture them
write that down and underline it twice
there's only one man who can take him
down I'll come back
hey you got a room for one more night
impact
ah Judas Priest get in this is 1934
gangsters submachine guns and you put
Cowboys on bunny in five Texas Rangers
forgive me Father for I have seen this
is a highly coordinated operation so
much pain and suffering roadblocks air
surveillance your time has passed cowboy
what the hell is the world coming to
used to be and have talent to get
published now all you got to do shoot
she used her foot to turn him over so he
could see what was about to happen Patsy
this has gone far enough when I take
them down
what a fine idea
[Music]
who are you Phyllis those were the bad
guys
come to the wrong place mister around
here cloud is king
ride my BK but I'm a Texas Ranger you
little [ __ ] now I didn't see me
[Music]
you